Bam. How you doing? You're on stage. Yo,
what's good, bro? How you doing? What's
up, man? You a Muslim? Yeah. Yeah, I'm a
Muslim. I'm a Muslim. All right. Pe uh
Paul and Jesus are better than Muhammad.
What do you think? Can I ask you why?
Why you say that? Muhammad is a sinner.
So, he's less than Jesus. Um Paul is
more authentic as a messenger of God
than Muhammad is. He has more witnesses.
He has signs. He has um a real message
from God, the fruit. So, okay. Well, I
mean, who were Paul's witnesses? Uh,
Peter, James, John, Ananas, Luke,
Barnabas. Did anybody ever see Paul get
his revelations or anything like that?
Yeah. Who who There were some soldiers
that were traveling with him who saw uh
they saw the light but didn't see the
person. They also heard the noise but
didn't recognize the voice. And then
anything after that or just that one
day? Yeah. Uh uh Ananas was a disciple
also who the Lord visited um and gave a
revelation that Paul received a
revelation from the Lord. So Ananas
received a revelation that confirmed
Paul's revelation. Okay. What about
Muhammad? So yeah, we there's been
different witnesses of um revelation or
when revelation came to prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him. Um obviously nobody
was there. Sorry. You were just saying I
was just about to ask you that. Yeah.
Obviously, nobody was there in the cave.
I mean, that doesn't seem to pose really
much of an issue, though, because I
mean, nobody was there when Mary had
certain revelation either. But then
again, you know, obviously there was, I
guess you could say, more physical
evidence after that cuz she ended up
being pregnant. Yeah, she ended up being
pregnant. Not only that, but also at the
same time that Mary got her revelation
from the angel, Joseph, her betrothed,
also received the same revelation from
the angel. So, you got two witnesses
that are receiving the same revelation.
So, it's not just Mary by herself. So,
that argument that Liiano brought up
backfires on himself. It's a stupid
argument. Please stop copying him. I
don't remember hearing that from Libyan,
but I mean, I've heard it before and
I've also heard y'all's responses, but
you know, anyways, um, so there also
have been um there's been witnesses of
people seeing a character. So, just
really quick, so because I want to make
sure we touch on this. So um Muhammad
Muhammad not having any witnesses to his
initial revelation while Mary and Joseph
had you know they're they're witness you
got Mary and Joseph who witness are
witness to their revelation who who
witnessed Mary and who witnessed Joseph
though I mean they did have the same
revelation that's they had the same
revelation so those are those are two
people who can confirm the the
revelation they received okay nobody
witnessed them but I guess I get your
point well yeah Joseph is a witness to
Mary would be a witness to Joseph
because they receive the same
revelation. You understand what I'm
saying? I get what you're saying. I just
the point I'm saying that nobody
witnessed them. Like nobody visually
witnessed them. What you're saying is a
different point which still stands.
Joseph visually visually visually
witnessed the angel and received the
same revelation that Mary received.
Yeah. Mary visually witnessed the angel.
Yes. Okay. I understand. So with with
Muhammad, he had nobody nobody nobody
nothing. Right. Right. Right. The first
time. Yeah. Okay. How did he how did he
know that it was how did he know that it
was uh an angel in the first place? Cuz
the hadith doesn't the angel doesn't
say, "Hey, it's me, the angel Gabriel."
I don't I don't know if he says that or
not in the hadith. But he didn't know he
didn't he didn't know at first,
obviously. I mean, he was freaked out
like like Daniel was when he was when he
received. wasn't freaked out like Daniel
was because Daniel wasn't freaked out by
the angel that visited him, but he was
freaked out by the vision that he
received that had all these beasts and
and you know things that he saw and the
angel came and comforted him and gave
him strength when he couldn't speak and
was felling down fainting. I I don't
know if that's true or not. Okay, let me
let me show you and then we're going to
compare and contrast. Okay. Sure. Sure.
All right. So, I'll show you. So we'll
go to if you can direct your attention
to the right side of the page. This is
uh we're going to go to Daniel chapter
10. All right. So it talks about how
then I heard the sound of his his words
and as I heard the sound of his words I
fell on my face in his deep words did he
sound and I Daniel okay there we go. I
Daniel alone saw the vision for the men
who were with me and did not see the
vision. Okay wait let's go up a little
bit more cuz I don't even know where
he's at or what's going on right now. In
those days I Daniel was mourning for
weeks. I ate no delicacies, no meat,
yada yada yada. And was that so was that
the feeling that he had of mourning and
all that? Was that from the visions? Was
from the vision? Yes. Okay. All right.
So then we can continue on. Mhm. I
lifted up my eyes and looked and behold
a man clothed with linen with a belt of
fine gold from Hold on. Just skip past a
couple verses. What did it It says
something about standing at the on the
24th day of the first month as I was
standing. Is this part of the vision or
is this him? Not yet. Okay. So, this is
not a vision. This is a real like this
happened to him in real life, right? On
the 24. The vision is real life, but
yeah. And like in in the on this side of
the plane. Yes. Okay. All right.
Continue. My fault. I'm just trying to
get a clear grip on it. We're not going
to read the entire thing, bro. We're
going to I'm going to go to the parts
where that's relevant. No, I just like
context. That's I wanted to know where
he was at. What was happening? I don't
like physics. So, so Daniel is receiving
a a vision, right? He said, "I lifted up
my eyes and looked and behold a man
clothed in linen with a belt of fine
gold from around his waist, his body
like yada yada yada." Right. Right.
Right. Kind of like an angel type. When
he spoke the uh and the sound of his
words like the sound of a multitude.
Okay. Right. And I Daniel alone saw the
vision. The men who were with them, they
didn't see the vision, but trembling
fell upon them and they they fled to
hide themselves. So, they knew something
was going on, but they didn't know what.
So, I was left alone and saw this great
vision and no strength was left in me.
Right? So, he was weakened and he also
fell in his face when he heard the words
of the man standing before him. Right?
Okay. And behold, a hand touched me and
set me trembling on my hands and knees.
So when he fell to the ground, the man
picked him up. The man He says he set
him trembling on his knees though. Yes.
So he fell to his face to the ground. I
fell on my face in a deep Oh, he f He
fed him up to his knees. Okay. Okay.
Exactly. So instead of beating him up
while he was still on the ground or
stomping him out or pressing on him even
further on the ground.
Why you Why you doing that, bro? Come
on. I just got to make sure we
understand the contrast here. Come on.
Come on. Instead of stomping him out,
putting his face in the dirt. No. Oh my.
What he did was is that he picked him
up. He helped him. Right. Right. Right.
Right. Set him on his on his hands and
knees, but Daniel was still trembling.
He was still scared. Can I pause you
right here? Sure. So if if So this is
the part that I was referring to, and
you can obviously correct me. The part
that I was referring to is where he was
obviously in some sort of deep fear once
he saw this man in front of him. So
whenever this angel, cuz I'm envisioning
as an angel, whenever this angel came to
him, he looked up and he saw this angel.
And by that, he's extremely freaked out.
He's fallen to the floor. He's this,
he's that. Everybody else ran from fear.
Like, I don't This is This is the part
that I was talking about. It's obviously
clearly an intense situation. This is
what I was referring to. I know. And I
And I want you to understand that.
Notice that it's not the angel who is
causing him this terror and fear, right?
But Daniel being startled and you know
seeing and hearing these things he's
scared right but the d the angel you
said something about beast I was trying
to catch that part I know but the angel
doesn't go on to then oppress him
further right but he of course of course
of course I was just I thought I was
incorrect cuz when when I said something
about when he when he ended up being
fearful or whatever you said that he had
visions of beasts and scary stuff that
was making him scared but this seems
like he was simply scared by the
presence of whatever was in front of him
and the sound of his voice, but I don't
I don't remember seeing anything about
any beasts. Okay. So, he says, "And
behold, a hand touched me, set me on my
knees, yada yada, and he said to me, oh
Daniel, men greatly loved, understand
the words that I speak to you and stand
upright, for now I have been sent to
you." So, do you see how he speaks
comforting words to him and he affirms
him? Hey, I'm a messenger. I'm sent to
you to help you, to bring understanding
to you. He's not choking him or pressing
on him or causing more fear. He's trying
to comfort him. Right. Yeah. All right.
When he said spoken this word to me, I
stood up trembling. Then he said to me,
"Fear not, Daniel, for from the first
day that you set your heart to
understand and humbled yourself before
your God, your words have been heard,
and I have come because of your words."
Right? The prince of the kingdom of
Persia withstood me 21 days. But
Michael, one of the chief princes, came
to help me, for I was left there with
the kings of Persia, and came to make
you understand what is what is to happen
to your people in the latter days. For
the vision is for days yet to come. So
just to be clear, cuz I I do see your
point, especially when you say the whole
fear not thing. I know where you're
going, but just to be clear, there were
no beasts, right? No. Yeah. He saw,
look, cuz if we go earlier, he's talking
about the vision that he saw before. Um,
the vision that he saw before the angel
in the in the third year of Cyrus, king
of Persia, a word revealed to Daniel who
was named
or whatever. Yeah. And the word was true
and it was a great conflict and he
understood the word and had
understanding of the vision. Right. So
he had that vision. However, 21 days
went by before the angel could come and
help bring understanding of the vision
he had, right? So, this whole all this
time, he's he's tripping. Daniel's
tripping, you know. But where are the
beasts? The beasts are in earlier
chapters, bro. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay.
All right. Cool. I'm just I'm I'm I'm
thinking I'm tripping. I'm just trying
to make sure I'm I'm not tripping, bro.
It's okay. So, comparison time. Yep.
Comparison time. Let's Let's keep going.
Um,
when he had spoken to me according to
these words, I turned my face toward the
ground and was mute. And behold, one in
the likeness of children of men, of the
children of men touched. Wait, what is
this? It's the same chapter. Oh, this is
right. Okay. This right below. Okay.
Okay. Yep. Then I opened my mouth and
spoke. So Daniel lost the ability, not
really lost ability to speak, but he was
so nervous, so scared that he couldn't
speak, right? He froze. But the angel
then touched him on his mouth and gave
him strength so that he could speak
again. Right. Right. I said to him who
was who stood before me, "Oh my Lord, by
reason of the vision, by reason of the
vision, pains have come upon me and I
retain no strength." So you see, it's
not the angel that scared him, but it's
really it's the vision that he had that
scares him. But what does that what does
that mean though? If the vision was
given by God and it's I mean obviously
it's supposed to be a revelation. Why is
it so scary? Are you for real? I mean,
clearly it's intense, right? Yes. So, do
you do you understand the difference
between the vision being what scared
him? Because he's human. It's intense.
So, he's frightened from the vision
versus the angel oppressing him and
causing his fear. You see the
difference? Okay. So, the vision
obviously is of the angel. I mean, do
you understand? Your your main point is
that he didn't physically touch him and
cause him any kind of discomfort is your
point. That's the point. He calls them
peace and encouragement, right? Okay. I
mean, yeah, that's I guess if that's
your point. Sure. That's what it says.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's your point.
Yeah. Okay. So, just to strengthen this
a little further, he says verse 17, how
can my Lord's servant talk with my Lord?
For now, no strength remains in me and
no breath is left in me. Again, one
having the appearance of man touched me
and strengthened me. And he said, "Oh
man greatly loved, fear not. Peace be
with you. Be strong and of good
courage." And as he spoke to me, I was
strengthened and said, "Let my Lord
speak for you have strengthened me." So
we see that the angel comes, comforts
Daniel, strengthens Daniel, encourages
Daniel, brings peace to Daniel,
strengthens Daniel. He doesn't oppress
him or cause him fear or makes him think
he's demonpossessed. Right. Right. All
right. Now, let's look at the experience
with Muhammad.
What you saying to be for? Because we
about to read some crazy stuff now.
That's crazy, bro. So, who So, what why
you got so much hate towards Islam, bro?
I mean, I know that there's Muslims out
there that might be disrespectful
towards your your your you know, Jesus
and and your Bible and Paul and etc.,
But why you got so much hate towards
towards Islam? Like the religion isn't
the people. You know what I mean? Islam
is not the people. Christians have done
bad things and Muslims have done bad
things, but like why why hate the
religion versus hating those people that
have done bad things or however cuz the
religion is the one that teaches those
bad things. Really? Yes. The religion
teaches that you can have, you know,
intercourse with children. The religion
teaches that you can go and sleep with
married women who you capture in war.
The religion teaches that you um got to,
you know, uh push, you know, not greet
Jews and Christians. No way. No way
you're going to talk about the treatment
of women captives in war, bro. Oh, yeah.
100%, man. You don't care. You've ever
taught your audience about Numbers 31?
Of course, bro. Okay. I want to see what
you say on that one. I never actually
heard you, but Ready to read this? Yeah.
Yeah. Go ahead. All right. So, let's go
ahead and uh because it's long. So,
let's skip straight to the uh I'm
familiar with it. So, you can we can par
uh paraphrase paraphrase. All right.
Cool. Not familiar. Cool. Cool. Cool.
All right. The truth descended on him in
the cave of Hera. It says, "The angel
came to him in it and asked him to
read." The prophets replied, "I do not
know how to read." Matter of fact, no,
go up a little bit. Does it mention the
visions that he would or the dreams he
was having prior in this hadith? I think
so. It says that he would receive dreams
in his sleep. Yeah. Mhm. Let me see. Let
me see. So the commitment scroll it was
in the form of good, righteous, and true
dreams. Okay. So he never had a dream
true like bright daylight. Okay. You
trying to waste my time? No, I'm just It
looked like it's very bright and
positive dreams that he's having prior
to the revelation. But we're, you know,
continue. I just wanted to I wanted to
see that part as well. All right. The
angel after the angel after the angel
told him to read and Muhammad says, "I
can't read." The angel then caught me
forcefully and pressed me so hard that I
could not bear it anymore.
He then released me and again asked me
to read and I replied, "I do not know
how to read." Mhm. Whereupon he caught
me again and pressed me a second time
till I could not bear it anymore. Why?
Why are you reading it like that, bro? I
got to I got to add, you know, I got to
add it to you, you know. Yo, bro, you
are funny, dude. I'm sorry. This is
funny. Keep going. Keep going, though.
My fault. All right. All right. All
right. Whereupon he caught me again and
pressed me a second time till I could
not bear it anymore. He then released me
and asked me again to read. But again, I
replied, "I do not know how to read or
what shall I read?" Thereupon he caught
me for the third time and pressed me and
then released me and said, "Read in the
name of your Lord who has created uh all
that exists has created man from clot.
Read and your Lord is most generous up
to that which he knew not." Then Allah's
messenger returned with the inspiration,
his neck muscles twitching with terror.
Don't laugh at your prophet, man. I'm
laughing at you, dude. You're a [__]
man. You're not doing No, don't try to
blame me though, man. Don't put it on
me. Your theatrics are are laughing. I'm
just reading the words. All right, let's
go. Let's go. Come on. All right. I got
to start over.
Then Allah's messenger. What is going
on, bro? You're a goofy, bro. Dude, I'm
just reading. Go ahead. Just read. Just
read. Yeah, just read. Then Allah's
messenger returned with the inspiration
his necks muscles twitching with terror
till he entered upon Khadijah and said
cover me cover me. They covered him till
his fear was over and then he said oh
Cada what is wrong with me? Then he told
her everything that had happened and
said I fear that something may happen to
me. Cadisha said never. What happened?
Oscar or something. Say you need an
Oscar Grammy or something. This is I
appreciate it. I appreciate it. I gota I
gotta make this at least, you know, I
got to drag, you know, graft in the
audience. Right. Right. Right. Right.
So, all in all, we already know how the
rest of this goes. Mhm. All in all, we
see that the this particular spirit
creature that appears to Muhammad Yeah.
is the cause of his terror and
oppression. Would you agree? I mean,
yeah. He he was left he was left fairly
in fear afterwards. Sure. Yep. Because
the the the the
so-called angel oppressed him, pressed
on him to where he couldn't take it
anymore and did it over and over again,
telling him to read when he can't read.
He's illiterate obviously, right? He
can't read or write. Right. Right. But
yet the angel's trying to force him to
do something he can't do without giving
him the ability to do it then and
presses on him and causes him to be
twitching and stuff coming out of that
cave. So I got I got a couple things. Um
firstly,
well this is this isn't really the most
relevant in the world, but I think I
think he tells him to recite if I'm not
mistaken. I don't think there's anything
the words the word isra in the ikra
could never could never mean recite at
all. I don't I'm not an expert, but I
just I just know from what I've what
I've known is just it means read. Echra
means to read. So, okay. So, I I feel
like I don't know if he had anything
there physically with him for him to
look at and read. I feel like he could
be telling him to recite, but you know,
uh you know, whatever. Anyways,
regardless, telling him to read, telling
him to recite, Muhammad is saying, "I
can't." And so, the the angel, the
spirit is telling him to do something he
can't do. He's saying he can't do I get
I get your point. So, um, and he's
oppressing him for it. Sure. Sure. Do
you see the difference? Yes, I see the
difference. Yes, I see the difference.
So, when I look at this now, when I'm
not using Christian glasses, when I'm
not looking from a Christian glasses, yo
yo, Christian glasses. Where's Where's
Travis Lee? Travis Lee, if you're
listening, if you're watching this at
all, please come on the stream on
YouTube, please. Cuz he's saying without
reading with Christian glasses, let's
show them what the Muslim glasses look
like. I got to show you my friend. He
actually has All right. Well, anyway, so
I only got like two points on it
honestly. Yeah, cuz I mean you raised
you raised valid points. I'm not going
to lie. But um without looking at it
from like using using the Bible as some
sort of criteria, like look at what the
angel did here as compared to what the
angel did here, without using it as a
biblical criteria and looking at his his
whole 23 years of revelation. this one
the the beginning of the instance
doesn't really pose much of an issue in
comparison to his whole 23 years of
revelation and the first example just in
that hadith being the visions and and
dreams he was receiving before being
pure and righteous and good dreams being
bright as daylight or however it
explained it secondly how the angel
announced himself essentially he
announced himself by telling him to read
in the name of the of the one who
created man from clot etc etc he he but
he didn't say who that was right But he
made it. He made it. What What else
would he be saying that for? What What
else could he say? Who is he talking
about? The one who created men from
Clyde. He could be talking He could be
talking about anybody. Any false deity
that um you know, he could be talking
about anything to deceive. So we would
just have to assume that we would just
have to assume that Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him doesn't know what he's
talking about when he says in the name
of the one who created man from clock.
Oh brother. Uh we we we can talk about
whether or not Muhammad knows what he's
talking about or not when refer when
he's referring to God. Well, that that
would be another thing. I didn't say
what if he knew what he was talking
about. I said if he knew what angel
Gabriel, peace be upon him, was talking
about. It doesn't How does he even know
he's talking to Angel Gabriel? He
Gabriel doesn't say, "Hey, I'm Angel
Gabriel." How am I supposed How am I
supposed to address him right now? How
am I supposed to address him? You're
you're supposed to address him as the
demon. The demon that approached
Muhammad. That's how you're supposed to
address, bro. You just got Look, I'm
going tell you why. All jokes aside. All
jokes aside, I'm telling you why. But I
but I also wanted to I also wanted to
bring up another hadith though and it
and it and it involves um angel Gabriel
and people being a witness to his
appearance as well. Okay, we can I'll
let you bring that up. I I'll let you
bring that up. But let's let's finish
this. Here's the point. The point is is
that he was pressed on and oppressed
unlike other prophets receiving
revelation from the from the angel. Too
aggressive. It's too it's too not
emotional enough. It's not soft and
cuddly and lovey. It wasn't peace be
unto you. said, "I get you. I get I get
exactly what you're saying." He didn't
announce who he was or where he was
coming from. None of that. Right. Right.
According according to the style that
you seen it happen in the Bible, no, he
didn't. Okay. Now, here's the here's the
interesting thing about this. You're
saying, "I need to do this. I need to
look at this without a biblical lens,
without you need to. Of course not.
You're a Christian. That would be like
if we don't." But here's the interesting
thing about this is why I'm asking you
where did he get this idea from that
this was an angel that visited him.
Where did he get this from? Oh, so
afterwards he spoke with Well, I think
Khadijah made a a mention first and then
he spoke with another man who was either
used to be a Christian or was a
Christian and he was able to say
something like, "Yo, this is familiar.
This is this is the same thing that
happened to so- and so prophet that was
an angel of God coming to you to
reveal." Exactly. And so that's war. So
the the reason why Muhammad thinks that
this is an angel, an angel Gabriel that
visited him is because Wara told him
this. Okay? Right? So Warah is telling
him this. Now when Wara is telling him
this, that means that all of this is
coming from a biblical lens. It's coming
from a biblical lens. So getting an
answer from that Christian, it is valid
in his biblical lens. Yes, for sure.
It's not coming from a biblical lens.
that it literally is coming from it
because he literally says it's the one
that appeared to Moses. I'm saying so
him his respon Yeah, we agree. His
response is coming from a biblical lens.
Yeah. And Muhammad takes that response
and runs with it from the for the rest
of his life. Well, I mean that that
doesn't mean that's the only thing that
was able to confirm that though. He had
23 years of constant revelation. Maybe
that confirmed that first instant. Sure.
I agree. missing the point. The point is
is that the knowledge that Muhammad got
or the information that Muhammad
received about what happened to him on
that first instance coming from a
biblical basis. Yes. From a from a
Christian. Yes, we agree. So, okay. So
looking comparing that we go to the
Bible and we see how the angels come and
approach the prophets and what is their
experience like. Never and you already
know this. You know the argument. Never
do we see an angel oppress someone cause
them fear cause them you know like
you're right. You're right. Okay. So my
question is my Oh yeah. Go ahead. Go
ahead. Go ahead. Okay. So based on that,
there's no reason to believe that this
experience here that Muhammad got was
from an angel of God. But what we do see
with these experiences is the same thing
happened to people who are oppressed by
demons in the Bible. This is what we
see. Okay? See, I feel like you're about
to bring up some examples about that. So
I wanted to pause you there. Um, and I
and I'm I'm asking this question because
I genuinely don't know. What was do does
the does the Old Testament or any of the
Jewish scriptures tell us anything about
Moses's revelations? Sorry, say that one
more time. Does anything in the older in
the in the older scripture or Jewish
scriptures or whatever tell us about
Moses's revelations? Yes. That's in the
Torah. Okay. So, they do tell us how his
revelations took place like how how they
how they were. Okay. Okay. So, what why
did the and again I was asking cuz I
genuinely didn't know. I've never read
up on on his revelations. But why did
that Christian I don't know his name.
you know his name or
why did he say yes we can recognize this
as the angel who uh revealed himself to
Moses. What what made him say that then?
Cuz he's not a real Christian. He's
false. He's false. He's a false when you
because when you look into it and we see
obviously that's false. So did he end up
becoming a Muslim or like what's he he
died he died before he could become a
Muslim but I think that if he stayed
alive he would have been a Muslim. Yeah.
So he was a Christian at the time not a
Muslim. He didn't believe in any further
prophets or anything like that. And he
was a Christian, a scripture reading,
abiding Christian. And he no recognized
this angel that came to him as the angel
that came to Moses. He wasn't a real
Christian. He was a gnostic. He was a
heretic. So we have history on him.
Well, but based on his beliefs, based on
what we see in his beliefs and how he
explains things. Yeah. I mean, just
based off of that. So we only have one
line up with Gnostic beliefs. We only
have one instance of him and is that's
this? No, I think there's a few others.
Um, I don't have them off the top of my
head, but there's a few others. Okay.
So, I'm not I'm not sure about that.
That's a little shaky for me cuz if if
if the only thing that we're going off
of is your opinion on what he believes
and you're calling him a heretic. No,
Catholics call. My brother, my brother,
my brother, you you miss Please don't
mis mistake what I'm saying. I'm judging
War, which says based off the Bible. War
says this is the same angel that
appeared to Moses. No, the heck it
isn't. So where did he get that from?
Nowhere. He's making it up. Or whatever.
Uh maybe some tradition that he's
following. That's not in the text.
That's not scripture. No, that's not
what I'm saying. So the only thing that
we have is that he he he must have just
came up with it from from from thin air.
That's the only thing that we have on
that as to why he came up with we can
posit that he probably was following a a
particular tradition. Who knows? But we
I don't think we can really confidently
point that. Whatever this is, it's made
up. It's made up. It's not in line with
the scripture. That's the point. I just
wonder why he would say that, man.
That's that's interesting to me. But,
you know, I don't know. Maybe wanted to
comfort him. He loved Muhammad. May
maybe, man. Maybe, man. He's a He's a
good man to love. Um, so
according to you, that's that's fine.
That's according to Dude, can I bring up
all of this? He's not a good He's not
good. That's the point of the live. I
know that's the point of the lie. I love
Jesus, too, man. Peace be upon you. You
don't love Jesus. Not you. Peace be upon
him, man. See right there. When you say
peace be upon him, that shows that you
hate him. You don't love Jesus. Oh gosh.
Peace be upon you, Avery. I don't hate
you. Would you would you say peace be
upon Allah? I don't I don't know why.
Why that be problem? So, all right. So,
say it. So, you know, say Allah, peace
be upon him. Subhanala is essentially
the same thing. No, it's not. No, it's
not. What does it mean? Say say peace be
upon Allah. Why? Why you trying to you
trying to click? What you What you Tell
me what's the problem with it. I'm
trying to what? You trying to clip. Tell
me what's the problem with it. That's
not That's not what I do, bro. That's
not my job. Tell me what's the problem
with it. I'm just not What's the What's
the problem with saying that? Huh? Say
it. If it's not a problem, say it. I'm
asking you. I'm genuinely curious. I
wouldn't sit here. I know. I'm genuinely
curious. If it's If it's not a problem,
go ahead and say Allah. Peace be up. I
clearly don't know something that you
know about this statement about saying
that. So tell me what's the problem.
Why? Why do you say peace be upon the
prophets? Why do you say that? I look at
it as a as a term of respect, as
endearment. I mean, that's how I look at
it personally. I don't see what I know
you're about to come with something. You
I'm looking at your face. I'm not dude.
I don't have nothing on my sleeve. I'm
not stupid, bro. We're on the internet.
I know you're not. Come on. What you got
to lie for? What you got for, bro? You
Bro, we're humans, bro. I know how this
go, bro. You guys are asking this
question so precisely. You're up on
You're up on game more than other
Muslims. However, my guy, you got some
sometimes you got to just trust me as
your as as your brother in humanity,
man. I I don't have nothing up my
sleeve. If you say, "Peace be upon the
prophets because it's a it's a phrase of
endearment and respect." That's all it
is for you. That's all it is. That's
fine. You can you can see it that way.
So then you if that's the case, you can
say upon Allah, right? I'm asking you
what's the problem with it. Well, where
do you say bro? There would be no reason
you would be wanting me to say this so
bad, dude. I'm not I'm not Look at the
chat. Maybe
I'm not looking I don't farm. I'm not a
cliff. Hey, somebody Hey, somebody in
the chat tell me, bro. What's the What's
the problem with that? What's he trying
to do to me right now, bro? Just be
real, bro. I don't want to sit here,
bro. Look, I'm I'mma be real, bro. Okay,
follow me. Follow me. Follow me. Follow
me. I'm coming. I'm coming. When you say
peace be upon the prophets, where does
the peace come from? I don't know, fam.
It's a It's from me. I guess they're
they're a creation. They let they gave
they came down here, gave messages and
and perceived persecution. I mean,
receive persecution and all this extra
stuff just to give the message of God.
It's peace. Peace be upon them. All
right. This So when you when you say,
okay, when you say peace be upon a
certain person, you're asking Allah to
grant them peace. Yes. You're asking
Allah to grant them peace. That's what
you're doing. Okay. So the reason why
that would be a problem if you said you
know let you know Allah may peace be
upon him may be peace be upon Allah
because that that would mean that you're
invoking someone else to put peace upon
Allah when he's supposed to be the
source of peace. You get what I'm
saying? So and this is my thing cuz I
know that you deal with a lot of trolls
and whatnot but me as a person I if I
believe I have I have respect for it.
So, you was about to get me to blaspheme
what I believe to be God for a couple
laughs and a couple views. I thought
more I thought you was playing I thought
you was playing with me. I thought you
was playing games. What do you mean? I
thought you thought I was playing games.
I asked you when you said when you said
that you like it would be no problem to
say peace be upon Allah. I couldn't
believe it. So, I was like, okay, say it
then. I couldn't believe it. I thought
you were trolling. That's what I'm that
this is what I meant the whole time when
I say you have some little thing you
about to bring up. That was the thing
that you were about to bring up and you
was just I I didn't I didn't bring that
up. I mean, it's not it's not like
something I'm holding over. I'm I'm
thinking it's something you know
already. If you didn't if you didn't if
you wasn't aware of that, then okay, you
know, my my bad for misjudging you as a
troll. Okay. What's up? What's up? I'm
not here to troll, bro. I'm genuine.
Like, I may not believe in Christianity.
Just And I'm I want to know some more
reasons why I should believe in
Christianity, bro. I know you be having
your your main um titles and points on
here. Okay. Do you want Do you want me
to tell you why you should believe in
Christianity? Help me out, bro. Help me
out. Okay. All right. I believe I
believe you're genuine. I'm a smart
dude, bro. I'm not stupid and I have a
lot of questions, but don't take it as
me trying to battle and debate and go
back and forth. I I'm just I'm just
chilling, bro. I'm learning what it is.
I'll take your word for it, you know,
from here on out. From here on out, I'm
going to take your word for it. I'm
going to treat you as a genuine person
who is open to for logic and truth. If
it's logical and it's true, you'll
follow it. If it's not, you're going to
reject it. That's That's what I'mma
That's how I'm gonna address you from
now on. I'm still I'm still ready for
your slickness because you you can be
slick. I'm still ready for it. But I'm
I'm genuine, bro. I'm a cool guy. I'm
chilling. All right. So, I'm going to
show you something and I'm going to uh
I'm going to uh show you why this is
this is what has like solidified
Christianity for me. Okay. Is this is
this something against Islam or is this
something like in Christianity? Like for
real, it's in Christianity, but I mean
by default it's against Islam, but it's
not Okay. Okay. I get Islam directly.
Okay. So, all right. So, this is Isaiah
chapter 53. Have you ever read this
chapter before? Oh, shoot. I'm
interested. I'm interested in your
response to this actually. Yeah. Come
on, man. I like this. Okay. All right.
Let's go through it. I' I've only ever
heard about Isaiah 53 in this context
where people use it for this and use it
for that. I'll be honest, I haven't
necessarily just read and stumbled upon
it. Isaiah 52 and Isaiah 54 as full
context, all this stuff. So, don't don't
I've only ever heard y'all argue about
it, literally. All right, cool. All
right, so it's only 12 verses. We'll
read all 12 for this for this
discussion. Not straight through, but
when there's points you want me to stop
at, stop me. Okay, I got you. I mean, I
know what points I'm going to stop you
at already cuz I want you I want your
questions on something, but go ahead. Do
your thing, man. All right. So, who has
believed what he has heard from us? And
to whom has the arm of the Lord been
revealed? For he grew up before him like
a young plant and like a root out of dry
ground. He had no form or majesty that
we should look at him um and no beauty
that we should desire him. He was
despised and rejected by men, a man of
sorrows and acquainted with grief. And
as one from whom men hide their faces,
he was despised and we esteemed him not.
Surely he has borne our griefs and
carried our sorrows. Yet we esteemed him
stricken, smitten by God, and afflicted.
But he was pierced for our
transgressions. He was crushed for our
iniquities. Upon him was the
chastisement that brought us peace, and
with his wounds we are healed. All we
like sheep have gone astray. We have
turned everyone to his own way. And the
Lord has laid on him the iniquity, the
sin of us all. I'll pause here. Okay.
Who does that sound like so far without
a biased mind? No Christian, no Muslim,
no atheist, no Jew, no nothing. Just who
does that sound like off the top of the
head? Well, hallelujah. It sounds like
good old Jesus Christ.
Awesome. All right. So, it sounds like
good old Jesus Christ. Why you sound
like Uncle Ruckus when you said sound
like Jesus Christ? Yeah. No, Uncle
Ruckus is a crazy example. That's wild.
That's wild. All right. Verse seven.
Yep. He was oppressed and he was
afflicted. Yet he opened not his mouth.
Mhm. Like a lamb that is led to the
slaughter and like a sheep that before
its sheer is silent, so he opened not
his mouth. Mhm. By oppression and
judgment he was taken away. And as for
his generation, who considered that he
was cut off out of the land of the
living?
Stricken for the transgression of my
people. So, so far we see cut off from
the land of the living. It says who
cons, this is a question. Who considered
that he was cut out of the land of the
living? Stricken for the transgressions
of my people. Yeah, it says it actually
says because it's talking about his
generation. and says it's taken away.
And as for his generation, who
considered like who would think of his
generation who like he's he doesn't have
any children. He has no who considered
that that what happened to him. Okay. So
it's kind of like okay. Yeah. I get it.
I get it. I get it. For sure. Cuz he's
cut off out of the land of the living
stricken for the transgression of my
people. Mhm. So obviously he dies,
right? Can we agree? That's what it's
what it's implying here is death. Yes.
Sure. Or or metaphorical for something
else. But yes. Well, it ain't it ain't
it's cut off from the land of living,
man. If you ain't in the land of living,
you're in the land of dead. All right.
Well, we'll see what that means, I
guess. All right. So, cut off of the
land of living, stricken for the
transgression of my people. And they
made his grave with the wicked and with
a rich man in his death. Although he had
done no violence, and there was no
deceit in his mouth. Mhm. Yet it was the
will of the Lord to crush him. He has
put him to grief. when his soul makes an
offering for for guilt. H
um he shall see his offspring, he shall
prolong his days. I want to see if we
can pause there. Okay, so the these this
is the two points that that have grasped
my attention and I'm pretty sure you're
you're already aware. Um now there's
actually there's actually three and this
one I just lowkey peeped. Um, explain to
me a little bit further on what it may
mean by when his soul makes an offering
for guilt. Is this guilt for is this
guilt for him? Is this guilt for his
people? What is this? It's everyone
else. It's everyone else. So, everyone
else has sins. Remember, look, it says
that the Lord has laid on him for our
iniquities. Exactly. So, he is the one
who's bearing our sins. Our guilt is on
him. Okay. And there's no and there's no
he he there's there's no way that that
can mean for his own guilt as well.
Absolutely not. Remember just it's
talking about how innocent he is. There
was no deceit in his mouth. He had done
no deceit. Yeah, that's right. He's
innocent. Okay. All right. That's what
like like I said, that was a point that
I just peeped just now. So now these two
are the ones I'm interested in. Okay.
His offspring and shall prolong his
days. Break those down for me, boss. All
right. Now, now, now, can I give you can
I give you my explanation on on why I
want you to break them down for me
first? Yeah, go ahead. All right, cool.
So, forgive me. Right. When it speaks
about seeing his offspring, I thought
about when I heard this, I thought about
a couple or really the only two ways
that this could mean is his offspring in
a physical sense where he would
obviously he would have kids, you know,
he would survive and blah blah blah,
which we know that couldn't be the case
for Jesus. I mean, I know that anyway.
Um, and then the other case would be
like a spiritual sense. You know, he
would live to see his offspring, people
that, you know, would would uh would
follow and, you know, be his followers,
etc. in that kind of sense. But the only
thing that's questionable with that for
me, and I don't know if this the if this
is the answer you're going to give me, I
just wanted to kind of lay this out on
the table first cuz I'm not no tricky
guy. Uh, the only thing that would be
questionable with that for me is um that
Jesus never spoke of him having any
spiritual children. He spoke of us being
the children of the father and that he
never gave those analogies or parables
of anything like that implying that we
his followers would be children of him.
Um so I wouldn't understand how to make
that connection but again those are the
two points that I got on that and that's
all my cards. Okay. So you're absolutely
right. It's the second explanation you
gave that it's a figurative talking
about um the ones who followed him and
the ones who followed in his footsteps
and and stuff like that. And so you
actually do have Jesus referring to the
disciples as his children. Okay. If we
go to John chapter 13, he uh goes on and
calls them and is it okay if I call you
here as well? Not to be like you know
rambunctious or nothing. Yeah, go ahead.
So what could imply before you show me
because I mean the way you fa to pull it
up I already know I I know you got
something bro but um before you show me
that what could make you imply here from
this this context here that um the word
offspring maybe in its original language
or the the the septuagian or whatever.
What could make you imply based off of
this that he would be talking about
spiritual followers or a specific group
of people rather than children offspring
or you know his biological you know.
Yeah. Well, well, the word in itself can
go either way and so it doesn't say
necessarily, right? It doesn't the word,
do you know in its original? Yeah, the
word is zera. The the word is zera in
the Hebrew. So seed or offspring. So um
it can either me be literal seed like
your literal offspring that you've you
know produced or it can be figurative
for those who follow you and stuff like
that. So like for example, here's an
example. Um, and if we go to same same
book, if we go in Isaiah, go to chapter
57, a few chapters over in verse 4, it
says this, "Whom are you mocking?
Against whom do you open your mouth wide
and stick out your tongue? Are you not
children of transgression, the offspring
of deceit?" The same word here, the zera
in the Hebrew. Uh, and there says that
they're offspring or seed of deceit. Now
we know that deceit is not a human who
has children or nothing like that,
right? But it's those who are practicing
deceit and lies and walking in that,
right? So those who follow after deceit.
So and who and who is this talking
about? And talking about the Israelites
here, talking about the Israelites.
Yeah. Some of the Israelites who are
going against God. So we the the word
zer can be used either way. In Isaiah
53, it doesn't necessarily say exactly
how. It doesn't necessarily ne
necessarily say if it's physical or if
it's figurative, but when applied to the
person, we can see that, oh, okay, it's
figurative, right? It works. It has to
be if we're talking about Jesus. Yes.
Exactly. So, um so yeah. And so in John
13, Jesus refers to um his disciples as
as the children. He calls them children.
Let me see. I'm trying to find you the
verse there. What about that? Um,
whatever. How long have you been doing
these streams, bro? Be pushing. What? 3
hours be like your max. Yeah, but lately
I've been going over three my three-hour
max. So, yeah, 3 hours is my is my
style. You trying to compete with uh
good old Orthodox Muslim or what?
Compete with them? You know, you know I
was here first, right? Yeah, bro. I'm
just messing with you, man. Yeah. So,
all all those other guys are are, you
know, I gave them the blueprint and
they're trying to copy off of it. But
Gotcha. Gotcha. Okay. That is what it
is. I'm trying to find the part where he
calls them his children. What part is
that? Hey, man. Y'all put put it in the
comments or something, man. I know.
Okay, here it is. Verse verse 33. So, um
if God is glorified in him, God will
also glorify him in himself and glorify
him at once. Little children, yet a
little while I am with you. You will
seek me. And just as I said to to the
Jews, so now I also say to you, where I
am going, you cannot come. So he calls
his disciples his children, right? And
in the next verse when he's talking
about him going away, he says, "I will
not leave you as orphans." Right? Um he
says uh where is it verse? Oh, here it
is. Verse 18. I will not leave you as
orphans. I will come to you. Right? Yet
a little while yet a little while and
the world will see me no more, but you
will see me because I live. You also
will live. So Jesus refers to to his
disciples as his children figuratively.
I don't know. I don't know if that means
they're his children though cuz they
definitely do call them children. But
that how how do we know that they're not
just children of the father? Like he
always calls them cuz he doesn't say
that. He's referring he calls them
themselves. And then like even even with
other people people that he's healed and
sent to go away, he'll call them
daughter or call them son. He says son
your s your sins are forgiven. Or
daughter go away. You are healed. Your
faith has made you whole. Like this is
how Jesus refers to those who have
believed in him sometimes. So do you
would you say that we're children of the
father like he always says or are we
children of him like I mean he seems to
have said as well. Yeah. So when it
comes to like um the heavenly father
like he's not the heavenly father right.
So we are children of God as we're his
children as in he's our source. It's
from him that we are from it's from the
father through Jesus. Right? Now, Jesus
can be figuratively our father in the
sense that we follow him and obey him
and follow in his footsteps and his
example. Right? So, he's the founder of
our faith. So, in that figurative way,
that's how he calls us or the disciples
his children. Not that he is the
heavenly the person of the heavenly
father. The person of the heavenly
father. So we could be considered
children of that the heavenly father the
creator but also what like spiritual
children of Jesus. You're spiritual
children of the father. You're spiritual
children of the father. You can be
considered figurative children of Jesus
if you're following his example and his
footsteps like the disciples. Okay.
Okay. Okay. All right. Um Okay. So, so
that's that and then the prolonging his
days. I would assume that's also
figurative and spiritual as well. Nope.
That's that's literal. That's literal.
He shall prolong his days. That means
why? Because he's coming back in the
second coming. Not because he's coming
back in the second coming, but because
he's being risen alive again. He's
resurrected. So his days are prolonged.
He'll never die again. Okay? So he will
prolong Notice this comes right after it
says that his soul is made as an
offering for guilt. He dies. His soul he
he's he died. But then it says he shall
see his offspring, right? Those who
followed him. And he shall prolong his
days. So his days will be prolonged.
They'll be extended. This is a
resurrection. Okay. Those two those two
are those two are valid. Um I do I do I
only got two questions on my mind right
now. Like right at this second that I
want to propose to you if that's fine
with you. I don't know if you in a rush
or you got other people to bring up or
what you got going on. I want to I
wanted to land this and then get your
thoughts on it. Okay. All right. Cool.
No problem. No problem. We only got two
verses left for sure. And those are my
those two points were my only like
contention. So I mean you I get your
answer on those. Uh they're valid. I
don't really got much much against him.
So, I mean, okay. Yeah, that's my take
on that part. All right, sounds good.
All right, so we'll finish it out and
then I'll get your total thoughts all
together. Yeah. So, out of the anguish
of his soul, he shall see and be
satisfied. By his knowledge shall the
righteous one, my servant, make many to
be accounted righteous, and he shall
bear their iniquities. Therefore, I will
divide him a portion with the many, and
he shall divide the spoil with the
strong. Because he poured out his soul
to death, and was numbered with the
transgressors,
yet he bore the sin of many, and makes
intercession for the transgressors. All
right. Actually, I want to pause cuz
that's another one that actually just
came to mind is cuz this is the Old
Testament. This is the Old Testament,
interestingly enough. And the Old
Testament is big time on um a father not
bearing the sins of his son and vice
versa. Um and and it speaks to that
heavily and um I don't know if it goes
into in detail about parables and all
that extra stuff, you know, touching on
it explicitly, but if it gives that idea
within the Old Testament, do you think
that Isaiah would be coming with this
prophecy about Jesus prophesying that
the exact opposite of that would be
taking place that a father can't bear
the sins of one another and somebody
else can't bear the sins of another?
that Isaiah would be prophesying the
exact opposite would be coming. Well,
no. So, it's not the opposite. What
Ezekiel says is that they will they have
to bear their own sins, right? They're
responsible for their own sins. Their
sins can't be put on their son or their
son can't take on the sin of their
father, right? Um but and then in
Ezekiel it continues to say that those
who uh basically repent, if the wicked
turn from their ways and follow my
statutes and my commandments um and
repent, then he will forgive them.
Right. Right. Well, part of repentance
when it comes to God's commands and
statutes is atonement sacrifice. They
have to give a sacrifice. That's not
that's not all the way true though,
Avery. That is true. Literally. So
there's so in every case in the Old
Testament for anybody that sinned for
any kind of sin there had by God there
had to be a a required sacrifice. Well,
let's see what the scripture says and
see. I would want to I would want to
hear the Old Testament on that though
cuz that I'm not going to give you I'm
not going to give you New Testament. I'm
going to give you the Old Testament that
says Luke. Oh, okay. You in Yeah, I
messed up. So, I'm aware of and don't
give me I mean correct me if I'm wrong.
I want to I want to give you this. I'm
aware of three circumstances
um that you're supposed to give
sacrifices for sins and they don't
always have to be blood sacrifices
either being um unintentional sins.
Let's let's just let's just hold on
though. Let's just read this and then
we'll get back to Isaiah 15. So I
believe I believe this might be Yeah. So
for the life of the flesh is in the
blood and I have given it to you on the
altar to make atonement for your souls.
For it is the blood that makes atonement
by the life. Mhm. So according to God's
commandment, atonement comes by blood,
by substitution of atonement. Okay. Now,
they used to give animals for this. Used
to give animal sacrifices and whatnot,
right? Herbs and and spices and stuff
like that if they could when they
couldn't afford it, right? But still
substitutionary sacrifice was the the
rule, right? Now, but for for those for
those specific instances though. Yes.
No, not just for specific instances. For
sins, for your sins.
For the life of the flesh is in the
blood and I have given it for you on the
altar to make atonement for your souls.
So, so what about all the
by the What about all the other
instances of people being forgiven
without sins in in in um you mean
without sacrifices? I mean without sorry
without sacrifice in the Old Testament
like like um Hosea. What do you mean in
Hosea? They're still giving sacrifices
in Hosea. Well, God says God says that
he doesn't desire he doesn't desire
sacrifices. Rather, he desires mercy.
No. No. Before that, he's talking about
how they're giving sacrifices in vain
because they're giving sacrifices and
then going out sinning again. Giving
sacrifices thinking that they're good.
Oh, as long as I give a sacrifice, I can
I'm good to go. And God is responding to
that. that he doesn't require their sac
that their sacrifice that he that that
means nothing to him, you know. So is it
really about the mercy? It's really it's
really about the heart condition, your
heart condition. And so he never did
away with the sacrifices. They still did
sacrifices in Hosea. Now, by the way, I
just wanted to show you how Isaiah 53 is
perfectly in line with the law that God
is still doing what he's been doing.
Atonement sacrifice is what clears the
soul. And so the Messiah is the atoning
sacrifice as revealed in Isaiah 53. And
and but what about say David? When when
David was forgiven, he didn't have the
sacrifice. David offered sacrifices. So
when he was forgiven for uh uh uh Beth
Sheba, when he was forgiven for Beth
Sheba, didn't he say didn't he say the
same essentially the same thing that's
in Hosea? Uh you don't sacri No,
brother. In in David's stories, he still
gives sacrifices, man. Right. I'm saying
that specific the even even when he was
asking for forgiveness he was grieving
and giving up sacrifices but God said
God said no you're going to get you're
going to get this punishment right but
um okay I want to read that if you don't
mind cuz I feel like I'm lost on that I
thought I had a whole another idea on
that have to be on your on your own time
brother I I want to focus on this
because we're losing sure
so with Isaiah 53 obviously like you
said it sounds like it sounds like it's
talking about Jesus you had those two
objections that you you said that it
makes sense. I cleared up. I mean, you
gave valid arguments. You gave valid
arguments. Yeah. So, with that being
said, then since this is about Jesus and
we see 700 years before Jesus is born,
before he comes on the earth, we see
what happens to him already foretold 700
years prior, right? Which means it lines
up with what happens here, right? which
means that God revealed this and that
this was part of God's plan the entire
time. God revealed Yeah, sure. Of
course. And and I don't see that it it
especially with those two objections
that you gave your um arguments to. I
don't really see where it conflicts as
hard, but it also doesn't conflict at
all with Israel being the suffering
servant. Um which I guess has been my
those two points that I brought up in
those in the verses and then that idea
that it doesn't conflict with being
Israel at all are my are my main
contentions with it. And now those two
verses are kind of out of the picture
essentially cuz you gave your Christian
argument, which I kind of understand.
But then the idea that it doesn't at all
um misrepresent the state of Israel
during that time either or however they
perceived it to be the suffering
servant. The fact that it doesn't
misrepresent that at all either kind of
still has that little bit of a question
mark for me cuz you know um how can it
possibly be the be Israel when Israel is
getting their sins taken care of? So,
that's the thing. Like, I've I've only
heard people's arguments on this. So,
and let's go ahead and shut this down
right now. Let's shut this down. Look,
you see Isaiah's speaker. Isaiah is the
one who's speaking. Okay? Isaiah is part
of Israel. Okay? Right? And it says here
in verse uh verse 8 that he's stricken
for the transgression of my people. This
is Isaiah speaking, right? This is the
Israelites. So he's stricken for the
transgression of Israel. This isn't
Israel. The the suffering servant is not
Israel. It's the Messiah who's saving
Israel. Make sense? Yeah, I get what
you're saying. I'm But I brought that
point up because there was there's
there's Yeah, there's that's an
objection, but it's not a valid
objection. It's silly. And I I want to
hear the objection again clearly before
I know that it's not it's not a valid I
just don't remember where I heard it at.
The objection is is that the suffering
servant is Israel. that when you That's
what I'm saying. I want to know why. I
know. I'm telling you. You got to
listen, bro. You got to listen. Okay.
All right. Go ahead. They're saying
their objection is when you read Isaiah,
the nation of Israel is identified as
God's servant. That's what they're
saying. That's their objection. So, when
it talks about the servant suffering,
they're saying, "Oh, well, the the
servant is Israel, so therefore it must
be the nation that is the suffering
servant." That's their argument. Okay?
Right. However, according to the
scripture, uh Isaiah, there's two
servants. It's not just Israel. There's
the the servant, the Messiah, who saves
Israel, the servant. You have the good
servant in in Isra in the book of
Isaiah. And you have the bad servant who
is blind, deaf, and dumb, who disobys
God continuously. And how God has to
save and they disobey, God saves, and
they disobey. But you have the righteous
servant of God who saves the failing
servant. Okay? So the righteous servant
who fails or saves like for example I'll
give you an example of this. Here's
Isaiah 42. In Isaiah 42 it mentions two
servants. The righteous one and the one
who fails. Okay look. Behold my servant
whom I uphold, my chosen in whom I my
soul delights. I have put my spirit upon
him. He will bring forth justice to the
nations. He will not cry aloud or lift
up his voice or make it heard in the
street. A bruised reed he will not
break. A faintly burning wick he will
not be quench. He will faithfully bring
forth justice. He will not grow faint or
be discouraged till he has established
justice in the earth and the coastlands
are await for his law. Right. Right.
Thus says God the Lord. His law. Yes.
Who created? Hold on. Hold on, brother.
Who created the heavens and stretched
them out. who spread out the earth and
what comes from it, who gives breath to
people on it and spirit to those who
walk. I am the Lord. I have called you
in righteousness.
I will take you by the hand and keep
you. I will give you as a covenant for
the people, a light for the nations to
open the eyes that are blind. So this
servant opens blinded eyes to bring out
the prisoners from the dungeon. So this
servant frees the prisoners from the
dungeon, from the prison, those who sit
in darkness. This servant brings out
those who are in darkness. He brings
them into the light. Right? So he opens
the eyes that are blind. He frees those
who are in the dungeons. He frees those
from who are in darkness. Right? He's
not the one who's blind. He's not in
darkness. He's not in a prisoner in the
dungeon. Okay? I am the Lord. That is my
name. My glory I give to no other. Nor
my praise to carved idols. Behold, the
former things have come to pass. New
things I declare before they spring
forth, I tell you of them. Now, that's
the same servant that's in Isaiah 53 53.
Yes. Now, let me show you the bad
servant, Israel. Watch this. Failure to
hear. See? Mhm. Hear you deaf and look
you blind that you may see. So, this
servant is blind and deaf. Who is blind
but my servant? Or deaf as my messenger
whom I send? Who is blind as my
dedicated one? Or blind as the servant
of the Lord? He sees many things but
does not observe them. His ears are open
but he does not hear. The Lord was
pleased for his righteousness sake to
magnify his law and make it glorious.
But this is a people plundered and
looted. They are all of them trampled in
holes and hidden in prisons. This
servant is imprisoned, right? They
become plunder with none to rescue,
spoil with none to say restore. So they
need rescuing. They need to be saved.
Who among you will give ear to this? Who
will attend and listen to the time to
come? Who gave up Jacob to the looter
and Israel to the plunderers? Was it not
the Lord against whom we sinned? So
they, this is Israel, the servant of the
Lord, right? This is the nation now. The
nation Israel is the servant of the Lord
who's blind, who's being looted, who is
deaf, who who uh refuses to see, who
refuses to hear, and they're in the
prisons, right? Um, and who has sinned
against God. So there's two servants in
Israel. I mean, in in the book of
Isaiah, there's the righteous servant
who saves Israel, who opens the blind
eyes, who brings them out of darkness,
and then there's the servant who failed,
who is blind, who is being looted, who
is um in prison, right, in the darkness,
who needs to be brought out. That's
Israel, as it says right here. Okay? So,
the the good servant is obviously the
good servant throughout Isaiah is Jesus.
The bad servant throughout Isaiah is
Israel. Exactly. And so when we get to
Isaiah 53, we see the good servant again
who's bearing the sins of Israel and
others and is saving everyone. That's
Isaiah 53. This is not the nation of
Israel. This is the Messiah. Okay. All
right. I mean, that's definitely valid.
I I don't got I don't really got much to
uh I don't really got much to argue
against that. I think those are valid
explanations. I would definitely like to
dig deeper as any genuine person would.
Um, yeah, I think those are valid. And
if I have any contentions with anything
we just talked about, I hope that even
given the topic of your next stream or
the next one I'm able to come on that
I'm able to maybe retouch on a couple of
those with you. Even I don't want to
just, you know, divert you from, you
know, what you got going on throughout
that stream. But no, no, you you you
have proved you have proved to be
exactly what you said you were. You said
that you were open-minded. You said that
you wasn't with the trickery or
trolling. Yeah. So yes, if you want to
revisit this stuff and you know solidify
more things and us talk about what we're
talking about, you can definitely come
because you're genuine. So you can ask
me whatever you want. And lastly, but
without without going any deep because I
know I'm going to get off of here. I
want to hear your your answer in like
three in like a short response if you
know about it cuz I want to I haven't
heard you talk about this before and I'm
I want to know. We'll talk about it next
time. Whatever it is, cuz it sounds like
it's off the subject. Let's talk about
it next time. Okay. Okay. I wanted
cherry on top. But for sure, I I'll dip
um you know, I'll try to come back and
see if we can revisit some more topics.
I appreciate you for talking to me, bro.
And y'all have a good one. Wait, before
you go, I don't I don't want you to put
like this is important. This is Isaiah
53 is important, bro. I Oh, I got this.
Don't worry. Oh, I got notes, bro. I
real life got notes, bro. I don't just
sit here and watch YouTube all day. I
actually do my like I do my due
diligence when I'm off here. I know that
people be talking they mean in in the in
the chat, and I respect it. You know, I
know how I get, you know, this Muslim
Christian that modern day 2025 stuff,
but I'm really trying to I'm really
trying to I I want I want real life
salvation. This game, you know. All
right. I'll see I'll see you later then.
I'll see you later. All right, brother.
You be safe now. All right. Peace. Yes,
sir. Got some pretty good guests today,
man. Pretty pretty amazing guest. Bam
was pretty dope. Pretty He was a good He
was He was fun, you know. He knew how to
laugh. I like guys like that. So, yeah.
Make sure you guys pray for Bam. Um
seemed pretty genuine. He proved to be
genuine so far. So, uh, let's hope that
he stays that way and we can continue to
have a lot of cut, you know, talks like
this. This is good.